Things a space is hard right now.
It's like going up a mountain on a unicycle with a backpack full of explosives,
incredibly slow. You can't transport a lot of stuff and you might die.
A rocket needs to reach a velocity of about 40,000 kilometers now to escape
from earth to get to that speed rockets are mostly containers for fuel,
with a tiny tip of payload. This is bad.
If you want to go to other planets because you need a lot of heavy stuff,
if you want to survive and maybe even come back.
So is there a way to get a space with less fuel and more payload?
[Inaudible].
The thing that sold most of our transport problems on earth is what you call
infrastructure. Whether it's roads for cars, ports for ships,
all rails for trains, we've made it easier to get to places.
We can apply the same solution to space travel space.
Infrastructure will make getting into orbit and out to the moon,
Mars and beyond easier and cheaper. Great.
But what exactly is space infrastructure? Unlike an earth space elevator,
which is currently science fiction,
that is a simple yet promising technology that does not require new
science, magic materials or huge investments.
And that has been tested successfully in orbit already cable and await,
known as a tether. The concept is so simple.
It's surprising what if we put tethers hundreds or thousands of kilometers
long into space and had spacecraft to use them as ladders to climb to higher out
Judes and gain.
Speed. This concept.
Is known as the sky hook. It works even better. If we make it spin,
the counterweight holds a long cable in place while it rotates around a circle,
a rotating tether slows down its tip relative to the ground to the bottom and
speeds it up at the top. Like a catapult.
This means that you can transfer energy from the tether and get a massive boost
when released more or less for free, equal to twice.
The tethers rotation velocity,
the specialized fibers already exist that can survive.
The extraordinary stresses a sky hook would be faced with to protect against
cuts and collisions from debris and meteorites.
We can thread our together into a web of redundant fibers.
Since our sky hook would pass over the same spot. Many times a day,
this would allow small reusable shuttles to catch up with it. Of course,
it's not that easy at its lowest point.
The tellers tip is dashing through the atmosphere at around 12,000 kilometers
per hour because of Earth's atmosphere. We can't low the sky hook too much,
or it will get too hot from Africa.
So it will dip to a height of 80 to 150 kilometers and no lower to
match.
This will need specialized space trough that can get to the tether while this
isn't exactly easy.
It's still much cheaper than getting a big tin can filled with rocket fuel to go
40,000 kilometers an hour catching the tip will be a challenge too.
There's only a short time window of 60 to 90 seconds to find a tiny thing in the
sky. Moving at Mark 12, to make this easier.
The tip could have a sort of fishing line that a kilometer long with a
navigation drone that helps the spacecraft connect.
Another challenge is keeping our sky hook in obese as more and more ships latch
onto it and pull themselves up. They use up the momentum that keeps it in place.
If we don't do anything, it will slow down and crash into the atmosphere. Yeah.
And here we can cheat the universe of bet.
The sky hook is a battery of orbital energy.
It's possible to the payloads coming in and being sent off arriving
ships, bringing humans and materials home to earth, add energy to the tether,
which it can give to other ships departing into space.
This way the tether doesn't lose any energy. The more we use it,
the cheaper it gets. If we're still losing energy with each boost,
we can recover it with smaller electric or chemical engines that regularly
correct the tethers position,
a set of Tavers one around earth and one around Mars could make trips between
the planets fast, straightforward, and low cost competitors rockets.
The earth tether would sit in low earth orbit to grab people in payloads and
fling them off to Mars.
Whoever catches them and slows them down for a landing on the surface in the
opposite direction. The tether could pick up the vehicle.
Traveling through Mars is thin atmosphere at only about 1000 kilometers an hour.
Not much faster than our airliners on earth and fling it back to earth to be
caught and lower down.
The tethers could shorten trips between both pennants from nine months down to
five or even three,
and reduce the scale of the rockets required by between 84 and 96 X percent.
Even better.
People be able to travel in a relative luxury as we could afford to invest in
passenger comfort. Tether travel would be first-class seats to Mars,
tethers around earth and Mars could provide the rapid and cost efficient
transportation backbone that would make space travel affordable,
but let's go further. Start from low Mars or risk.
A tether could boost ships to the asteroid belt.
The first craft sent to a new asteroid would need rockets to slow down at its
destination.
Subsequent arrivals might find a tether waiting to catch them and send them back
for free. Getting to asteroids.
Cheaply is a major factor in opening up the resources of the solar system.
Precious metals and valuable minerals could be delivered to Mars just weeks
after they were cut out of their asteroid.
They would be the perfect building blocks for our interplanetary similar
ization, but why stop here? Mars moons are very convenient,
no other moons in the solar system orbit that close to that planet.
The Phobos is so heavy that we don't need worry about slowing it down,
making it the perfect attachment point for super tethers,
just under 6,000 kilometers long,
the lower tip would fly just over the surface of Mars and be very easy to catch
the upper tip can fling ships all the way to Jupiter and Saturn.
The same super tether can also bring the inner solar system closer.
Venus and mercury are a single swing away.
Unlike Mars they're bursting with soda energy and are rich in minerals
in the long term,
nothing is stopping humanity from constructing a zero propellant transport
network for the terrestrial planets centered on the Marsh and moons.
Tethers are a comparatively cheaper and sustainable solution to making space
travel affordable.
And the rest of the solar system accessible for exploitation and exploration.
Considering that we have the technology to build them today,
there's really no good excuse to wait. Any longer.
Parts of the solar system are far away, but they could be very close.
Speaking of stuff, that's hard to reach, but it doesn't have to be knowledge.
Our friends from brilliant can hook you up to a universe full of explosive ideas
and fun courses.
Brilliant is a website that helps you tackle science in a practical way with
interactive problem solving courses and daily problems in maths and logic and
engineering.
Each problem gives you all the tools you need to crack complex topics all by
yourself. It's learning by doing, but with your brain instead of your hands,
use your curiosity to get to the bottom of puzzles and courses about things like
classical mechanics, astronomy, gravitational physics, and much more.
If you click the link in the description or visit brilliant.org/nutshell,
you can sign up for free and learn more things than you can imagine.
And there's an extra part for coats because aren't viewers the first 688 people
to use the link, get 20% off their annual membership,
which lets you view all the daily problems in the archives and unlock every
course. Brilliant helps you end your day, a little smarter.
You might get hooked on the experience.